nie im leben darf man mehr in
irgendeiner form [ __ ] sagen dieses buch
heißt mein erster nie gezüchtet
mein erster [ __ ] das ist natürlich
heutzutage ein titel der wirklich sehr
sehr problematisch ist ich finde dieses
wort nicht akzeptabel und man wartet
natürlich auf diese brisanz in der
geschichte die dann auch tatsächlich
eingelöst wird
wo er sagt einen gar nicht so einfache
titel glaube ich sind immer ein bisschen
problematisch aber sie sind natürlich
sehr geschickt weil sie wie auch das
dahinter stehende produkt darauf hin
zugeschnitten sind dass man es rasch
konsumiert herbst will ich uns im jahr
wie viele ist der absolut unübertroffene
titel eines buches den es gibt es gibt
keinen titel der besser ist als dieser
wirklich nicht sagen und spontan durst
schon verloren dann habe ich noch was
wir wirklich van der beek es ja auch
eine spezielle freundin von mir vorfahrt
gehabt ganz zauberhafte sachen über mich
gesagt schlug die frau mit dem hund
heißt das eine buch und das andere buch
heißt sondern mutige ritter die dame mit
dem maghrebinischen hündchen das hat man
oft titel ähnlichkeiten wie war das bei
deinen büchern ich liebe ja titel ich
führe extra dateien über titel dino
titel enthalten
und dann habe ich oftmals mehrere
vorschläge hast du erst den titel des
buches und dann überlegst du dir welches
buch du dazu schreit hasst oft wenn ich
das buch schreiben deskriptive titel wie
eine zusammenfassung des inhaltes in
wenigen wochen sein gebrochenes das
entfernt sind tatsächlich okay jetzt
haben wir langsam auf
[Musik]